Okay, so this is your foot bath tutorial.
So at this point, you should be familiar with using your rife machine.
So the pieces with your foot bath are going to be a bucket, a true rife insert here
which actually will be placed right into your water and then your grounding pillow.
You will also want to get either sea salt or Himalayan salt.
This is what you will be adding into your foot bath.
So the first step is to fill up this bucket with this submerged into it about halfway
here.
Then you will add a tablespoon of your sea salt and you'll just sprinkle that into
the water.
And then your grounding pillow will be placed right behind your back when you're seated
in your chair.
And you'll want to wear a thin shirt or just your bare back to keep you grounded while
you're doing this.
The next piece is you will plug in the two cords, the one, the smaller one, connects
to your grounding pillow.
That goes right into your rife here where it says GRLED, you'll plug that in.
And then where it says ion is where you'll plug in the big thick one.
This is the device that goes into your foot bath.
So you'll plug that in.
So they both get plugged in here.
And then you take this little toggle and you flip it to bath.
Then on your laptop for your true, in your true rife icon, you already have it open.
You go to your open home to get to all of your programs.
And then you will have in your folder that says AA your name when you open that it'll say
ion pro wave down here.
If you have a specific program, if you do not have a specific program and you just got
this for purposes of detoxing or other things you might be using this for, you go right
here into the ion pro wave folder.
And then you pick whichever program you want.
So I'm just going to go right here to the detoxification clear line, go to open.
You see here the image pops up, tells you which program you're in and then you hit run.
And this will run just like your bulb does.
The effect light then turns on on your rife machine.
And then it starts flashing blue when it is on as well.
If you want to pause this, you run it just like you do with your hammer bulb and you hit pause.
If you want to stop, you hit stop.
Typically, these programs are about one hour long.
When you are finished using your foot bath, make sure that you switch this back to bulb.
And then you are ready to use your hammer bulb once again.
And you can unplug your two cords here because you are no longer doing the foot bath.
And then you will be able to dump out the water.
The water will then be different color.
It will be dirty and you can just pour that right out, rinse out the bucket.
You can take this device, rinse it under the water, get everything cleaned up.
I do recommend before you take your feet out, you have a clean pitcher of water next to
you and you rinse them off over the bucket and then dry them off before you just get out
of there.
Just give us a call if you have any other questions.
Thank you.